I wonder what he's doing here like is  looking for something just 15 up less  tips got yourself a bartender named Sam  Sam hey every from oh you're in their  house but I'm nobody everyone Tony just  seems like there's something more your  story than just thumbing around  I figure that we're supposed to enjoy  every moment and try to make a  difference do excuse me for just a  minute they can you telling her the  librarian  you know consistency  who's this white knight Sam Doonby  don't be trying to check you out  nobody knows nothing about you saying  you don't know one thing about me I know  all that I need to know  I just want to take you as a family for  what you did yesterday  oh look touch me  Sam do you want to tell me what just  happened in there that look like you  seen a ghost maybe I have you ever  killed again a fool I think I'm falling  in love with you mr. Dubey Sam to be  man's beware this used to be a nice  quiet town  can you show them